PROFESSOR: The humanities,
to me, particularly at MIT,
are essential, indispensable, to
help break those infamous walls
and build bridges.
Why?
Because the humanities are the
only disciplines of philosophy,
psychology, linguistics,
history, writing, women
and gender studies,
that can give us
the tools to understand
how phenomena connected
to race, to language,
to religion, to gender,
to sexual orientation,
to have the tools to be
able to understand
how they can be used
or misused for domination
or for liberation.
This is the only
group of studies,
of disciplines, that
give us those tools.
As Paulo Freire and
[INAUDIBLE] said,
we have to learn
to become literate.
Not literate just being able to
read, but being able to, as we,
as Freire says, to read the
world, and read the word.
Because as we read
the word, we have
to understand the impact
of what we read on the way
the world works.
And the way the
world works often
is based on these hierarchies
of power that are often
embedded in the text we read.
But we're not able to critically
understand those texts
and see how they create a myth,
or maintain those hierarchies
of power, then we're
going to become
part of these hierarchies
We help maintain them.
So the humanities
give us the tools
to be critical about
these hierarchies
and be able to distance
ourselves from them,
and perchance to even
undermine those hierarchies,
and create more
inclusive, and more--
kinder, more humane societies.